Thanks to everybody for coming.
My name is Stephen Naron and
I'm the director of the Fortunoff Video Archive
for Holocaust Testimonies.
The Fortunoff Video Archive, which began
taping testimonies in New Haven back in
1979, contains more than
4,400 testimonies of survivors,
witnesses and bystanders of the Holocaust.
It encompasses something like 12,000
hours of recorded material in over a dozen
different languages recorded over the last 40
years in over a dozen different countries.
Today, in honor of Black History Month,
we intend to examine one of those testimonies
in the collection, the testimony of an
African-American veteran of the Second World
War, Leon Bass, who entered the camps
shortly after liberation.
I will be doing this with the help of our
speaker this afternoon, Anna Duensing.
Anna is a doctoral candidate in a
joint program for history and African-American
studies at Yale University.
Her research, writing, and teaching focuses
on the United States in the world, specializing
in race and empire in modern U.S.
history, African-American history,
transnational and global history.
And her dissertation, titled Strange Victory:
Cold War, Civil Rights, and the Long Shadow of
Fascism, explores antifascist
thought and action in the 20th century Black
freedom struggle, Black radical theories of
fascism in the United States, and the role
of the far right with an opposition to the civil
rights movement.
Today, Anna will be speaking on racism, fascism
and the Jim Crow military as seen through the
testimony of Leon Bass.
Anna, we're delighted you're here.
You have the floor.
Thank you so much, Stephen, for the
invitation to give this talk.
Thanks everybody, who unfortunately I cannot
see, who has logged in to
listen. I realized this morning
that it has been exactly one year
to the day that I was last in New Haven
and on campus at Yale.
And, well, I'm sorry
we can't all be together in person.
And while I recognize the gravity of
the impending one year milestone of this
catastrophic pandemic, I'm nonetheless glad to
be here with you all.
And I also welcome anyone who's
joining us from the greater, beyond, beyond New
Haven that is able to join us in the
setting.
So I'm going to try to speak for around 30
minutes and also show around 10
minutes of clips before opening it up to
questions and comments.
As Stephen Naron said, I've built this talk
around the story and the experiences
of an African-American World War II veteran
named Leon Bass, whose oral history is
housed in the Fortunoff collection.
And Bass was among the soldiers who participated
in the liberation of Buchenwald, which was just
outside the German city of Weimar.
And much of his testimony centers around
that unexpected and life altering act
of eyewitness.
But he contextualizes that experience within
memories of racial oppression in the United
States, notably what it was like to
serve in a segregated army,
relegated to an all-Black labor unit when he
stepped through the gates of Buchenwald.
And after getting out of the army--army, Bass
became an educator and eventually a high school
principal in the Philadelphia area.
And you can really see that expertise,
that demeanor, the demeanor of a lifelong
educator in every aspect of his testimony
and his commanding presence,
which you'll see is solemn but also really
affable, his storytelling is powerful
and accessible language.
But most of all, his steadfast commitment
to teach. I'm really trying
to honor all of that in this talk.
And I'm going to draw on his testimony, but
threaded together with it with a bigger history
in order to tell a story about Jim Crow America
in the 1930s and '40s, about
young soldiers navigating the racism and other
indignities of the Jim Crow army.
But more so, I want to talk about how
African-Americans responded to the rise of
fascism in Europe, responded to
Nazi Germany in particular, and responded
to the escalating policies of antisemitism and
violence under that regime.
And then toward the end of the talk, returning
to the testimony of Leon Bass, I'll conclude by
discussing in brief how African-Americans
responded to the Holocaust and how it informed
their understanding of ongoing racial violence
and white supremacy in the United States, and
also set the stakes for the postwar
Black freedom struggle.
And I do want to note that in this talk, I'm
going to be showing one photograph taken during
the liberation of Buchenwald that features the
corpses of victims.
I'm also going to be showing two political
cartoons that depict lynching,
the victims of lynching in order to critique it.
So.
In September 1933, mere
months after the Nazis had come to power,
a foreign correspondent for the Baltimore
Afro-American wrote an article weighing in on
the public debates over the escalating rhetoric
and racial policies of the Nazi dictatorship.
For the past, for the past few months, a
controversy on the Jew in Germany has been
raging, he wrote, and it was inevitable that the
Negro in America should be projected onto it.
He was referencing debates in the Paris edition
of the Chicago Tribune that juxtaposed the
situation of German Jews to those of
African-Americans in the Jim Crow South.
The article meant to intervene in this
comparison, differentiating between the Black
experience of racial oppression in the United
States and the status of Jews confronting,
in his words, the intensely narrow nationalism
and antiquated theories of race promoted
by Adolf Hitler.
First of all, this journalist argued,
Hitlerism appeared to enforce a vastly
different social order than US race hate.
Nazi Germany lacked the anti-Blackness and color
lines that criss crossed every aspect of life
back home.
In his words, the German Jew was also largely
indistinguish-- indistinguishable from the
so-called Aryan German, and Black residents,
tourists, and students moved freely throughout
Germany as they did throughout the rest of
Europe.
In this way, he argued, the persecution on
the rise in Germany was not strictly about race
as he understood the term.
He noted that the majority of Germans being sent
to the newly constructed concentration camps
were overwhelmingly socialists and communists.
Comparison slipped too quickly into competition,
he remarked. In the Jim Crow racial regime
was a singular monstrosity.
However, he admitted there was no denying that
Hitler's talk sounds strikingly like the
frothings of a Southern Cracker.
I want to hone in on this idea of comparisons
between Jim Crow and Nazism being inevitable,
as well as the nature of the particular
comparison and sort of compare and contrast that
this journalist carried out in this very early
moment in the Nazi regime.
The Black press had honed in on the grammar of
race and nation undergirding fascism while
covering Italy in the decade prior.
Hitler's rise to power only fueled the
comparative editorial fire, which not
only noted shared affinities and agendas,
and made distinctions in policy, ideology
and national context, but they also
tracked cross currents of admiration, imitation,
and direct exchange between right wing state
and non-state actors throughout the interwar
era.
African-American perspectives on fascism and
antifascist resistance in the 1930s and '40s
are a crucial resource for us in the ongoing
contemporary debates over fascist analogies
and the fascist potential of the United States.
This historical archive is rich, offering
a cumulative judgment that fascism and power
in Europe and exclusionary nationalistic
militant white race pride in the United States
share common roots, enemies and ambitions.
For many white Americans, fascism initially
offered a kind of screen upon which they could
project their own anxieties about US social,
economic, and race relations.
Depending on their politics then, they might
celebrate or denounce relative proximity.
By contrast, early African-American assessments
of fascist parties, movements, and regimes
by both radical intellectuals and in popular
discourse, they, this
discourse functions more like an indictment and
a warning, not only about what was happening
abroad, but also the implications of those
developments for their own lives.
African-Americans recognize the centrality of
racial antisemitism to Nazi politics well
before their white counterparts, and they were
quick to frame the fascist embrace of race
and nation as nothing new.
And indeed, soon enough, many Black activists,
intellectuals, journalists, and everyday people,
including the journalist I quoted at the start
of this talk, they arrived at the conclusion
that these comparisons and connections were
inevitable because Jim Crow and fascism were
undeniable bedfellows.
In turn, they signaled alarm over what
they perceived as dangerous new precedents
of racialized citizenship, social control,
state violence, and patriotic militarism
that would fundamentally transform the world as
they knew it.
Assessing the historical archive,
African-American responses to European fascism
and the Holocaust are a mixture, a broad
mixture of moral outrage, grassroots
movement building, political opportunism,
and anxious concern for the future, for humanity
as a whole.
For race conscious African-Americans engaged
in a growing Black public sphere of the 1930s,
sensitivity to the race thinking and imperial
ambitions undergirding fascist politics
threaded together these complex and sometimes
contradictory responses.
In early 1936, the great poet and
major public figure Langston Hughes expressed
the sentiment that bound these manifold
viewpoints together when he said fascism
is a new name for that kind of terror the
Negro in America has always faced.
This kind of terrorism is extending more and
more to groups of people whose skins are not
black.
Fascism proved a flexible and highly potent
point of reference for African-Americans.
They approached fascism as an arsenal, as a
powder keg really, of ideas,
cultures, agendas and tactics
rooted in racial colonial violence.
These social and political forces to them were
already in circulation, already at work in their
own communities and in their own histories,
yet newly fortified and fanatic in the context
of widespread social conflict and global
economic collapse.
The scholar Michael Rothberg describes this work
in the postwar era as multidirectional memory,
the idea that historical actors weren't merely
comparing events and atrocities in a competitive
struggle for recognition, but rather as
a way to understand their worlds and better
articulate their own experiences of
racial violence and state oppression.
Black theories of and responses to fascism
in the 1930s and '40s, again from
a place of relational political engagement
with Europe, would argue that Europe was not
the sole entry point for understanding and
combating fascism.
This discourse tended to follow a calculus of
family resemblance, wary of fascism's
capacity to travel and adapt to diverse
national contexts.
And here, I think, is a good example
of the kind of comparative relational work that
I'm describing, a rhetorical move that was
pretty common across the interwar and war time
eras. On the left,
you can see an anonymous woman slain by the
Nazis with reference to the Warsaw ghetto.
And on the right, you see the body of Cleo
Wright who was lynched by a white mob in
Sikeston, Missouri, in early
1942 after assaulting a white woman in her home.
And this lynching had garnered international
attention because it was the first to occur
after the United States had entered the war.
And because of this added pressure
of the global eye, was also the first case
of lynching taken up by the US Department of
Justice.
The same day that this cartoon ran, however,
the Black newspaper, The Pittsburgh Courier,
published another compare and contrast piece
by a white liberal that argued the difference
between Nazi terror and Jim Crow persecution
was less in-kind and more in terms of
historical, the historical direction of
each social order.
So in the words of this writer, Hitler has
crassly reversed the clock of civilization,
whereas we in America have been moving slowly
toward more tolerance.
These debates in the Black press, in the Black
public sphere, were not preoccupied with
taxonomy, but rather with the vicissitudes
of the world in which African-Americans lived,
viewed against the backdrop of
dictatorship, total war and genocide
in Europe.
They show a complex combination of sympathy and
self-interest.
They often sought to highlight American
hypocrisy and frame Jim Crow as a backwards
anti-democratic system.
They aim to expose the very real models
that the Italian fascists had in the European
scramble for Africa, or the Nazis had
in US settler colonialism and the Jim Crow
South.
In response to the passage of the Nuremberg laws
in 1935, for instance, one
journalist wondered, "what are Jim Crow
laws but fascist laws?"
Likely unaware of the extent of efforts that
Nazi lawyers had taken to survey US racial
legislation, he ventured, "it is difficult
to believe that Hitler, to save time,
did not copy them directly from the Southern
statutes and from the unwritten laws
of America against Negroes."
In other moments, this connective work
manifested as grassroots global solidarity,
reformulating one group's freedom struggle
toward a more universal politics, as was
the case with the global Black-led mass movement
that rose in response to the Italian invasion of
Ethiopia in 1935.
In other moments in public discourse on fascism,
African-Americans arrived at the idea that there
was a unique form of US fascism, born of racial
slavery and its many legacies.
This was often called our native brand of
fascism, and this brand came in forms
as varied as lynch mobs, the Klan, the police,
strike breaking, union busting and other attacks
on labor. The South, as you can imagine,
very often took center stage.
But their assessments also acknowledge the
United States as a whole with its faulty
democracy and increasingly domineering presence
on the world stage.
Black antifascist discourse and activism
didn't show a growing concern over Nazi
sympathizers and actual fascist movements in the
interwar United States.
But the critique was much more often centered on
the insistence, centered on critiquing that
insistence on gradualism you heard in the
article I quoted, the idea
that the country was moving slowly toward more
tolerance.
And the response to that in light of what was
happening in Europe, in light of
everyone's feeling that things were about to get
much worse, the response was gradualism
isn't enough.
And you can see a bit of that attitude in this
cartoon, which was published two weeks after
Kristallnacht and this cartoon
ran with the accompanying editorial,
"Colored America is also shocked.
But there are some things that Colored America
cannot understand about white America's reaction
to the atrocities.
They could not understand was humanitarian
support and widespread condemnation
without self reflection on the United States's
own history and present realities."
The article went on, "How could you be shocked
over ransacking when the United States had,
quote, robbed Indians of a whole continent?
How could you be shocked over these killings
when five thousand lynchings were on record?
How could you be shocked over racial pollution
laws when similar legislation ordered
American society?"
With the onset of war, and especially with the
US entrance into the conflict in late
1941, this argument gained a great deal of
political power.
The United States was not yet a fascist state
within Black antifascist analysis, but
the pervasive presence of domestic Hitlerism,
as they often called it, put it in complicit,
dynamic relationship to the regimes of Italy,
Germany and Spain, as well as those of European
colonial rule.
This stance disputed the framing of the conflict
of World War II as one of democracy
versus fascism, freedom versus tyranny, good
versus evil.
It challenged the idea that
the US racial order was an acceptable system,
emphasizing its hypocrisy, its vulgarity
and its inhumanity.
This argument found its clearest expression in
the Double V campaign, which was first
championed by the Pittsburgh Courier and called
for victory over aggression, slavery,
and tyranny both abroad and at home.
And in many cases, it was clear, it was made
clear that this meant double victories against
fascism, the American variety, as
well as the European brand, as
one writer put it.
And it's my sense that at this point it's really
no longer about compare and contrast.
Many, many simply
couldn't understand fascism as an entirely
foreign concept.
The lines were far too murky and
it wasn't this clear, you know, fascism
was not as clear opposite, or sort of other of
American democracy, but much more like a
doppelganger.
And at times, of course, invocations of
Hitlerism did function as a simple
shorthand, or signifier, or insult.
But the idea of a unique American fascism
had really taken hold and
it got to the heart of a lived experience
of racialized rightlessness within a liberal
democracy.
And the scholars, Bill Mullen and Christopher
Vials recently expressed this idea
really well.
They wrote, "for people of color at
various historical moments, the experience
of racialization within a liberal democracy
could have the valance of fascism.
That is to say, while a fascist state in a white
supremacist democracy have very different
mechanisms of power, the experience
of racialized rightlessness within a liberal
democracy can make the distinction between it
and fascism murky at the level of
lived experience.
For those racially cast aside outside of liberal
democracy's system of rights, the word 'fascism'
does not always conjure up a distant and alien
social order."
The idea of an incipient American fascism
as expressed through the Double V campaign,
raise the stakes of what would happen if they
fail to succeed on both fronts.
As one editorial from The Chicago Defender put
it in 1942, "all
of Negro America is revolted at the monstrous
atrocities Hitler is heaping upon the Jewish
people.
We who are Negroes know that if Hitler wins, we
too will be the victims of slaughter of even
greater magnitude.
If Hitler wins, the poll taxers of the South
who now use lynching as a weapon of terror
will use it as a weapon of extermination."
And as you can see from these images on
the screen, Double V was also rooted
in patriotism and win the war
gusto and it helped inspire and cohere
the official logic of patriotic antifascism
so central to the American war effort.
Wartime civil rights efforts really
marked a point of no return for federal
policies, federal support of racial liberalism.
That's the moment you really start to see a sea
change regarding federal support
of policies of racial integration.
And civil rights activism during the war
also pushed many white Americans to
to really confront issues of racial inequality
in significant ways, giving rise to new
standards of tolerance and new terms
of acceptable language and behavior.
And it's in this moment that Leon Bass
enlisted.
Bass was born and raised in Philadelphia.
He grew up in predominantly
Black neighborhoods, went to mostly all Black
schools, and his parents, who were former
sharecroppers from South Carolina, they they
kept him, they seem to have kept him very
sheltered about the full force
and structural violence of Jim Crow
and racial violence in the United States.
However, that all changed when he
when he joined up.
Twenty years old by the time the Second World
War had become a reality.
No, I was--I, I finished school
in 1943 and I was eighteen.
And that's when I became part of the military.
And you, how did you become part of the
military? Did you volunteer or get drafted?
Yes. I went out and I, I volunteered
and I was to go out with the next group.
And when I went down to the induction center,
institutional racism smacked me right in the
face, because
the sergeant was there and
he told me to go one way.
When I went through the door and he told my
white friends to go another way, because
my country practices promulgated and
promoted institutional racism
and the military was one of the largest to do
just that. And so, I went into an all-Black
unit save for the officers.
They were white, but
all of my comrades in arms at that time were
Black.
Bass was promptly sent down south for basic
training.
Eight of the nine largest army training camps
were located in the South, so this was a common
experience for Black GIs.
And that also meant the majority of white
officers overseeing their training came
from the south as well.
And Bass found his time in basic training
extremely demeaning and disaffecting,
not only for the daily degradations of
Jim Crow, but also for being relegated
to a labor unit.
Was it your perception, though, that the Black
troops generally, though, fully
understood the fact that while
the rhetoric of the war against Nazi racism and
so forth was fine, in practice,
the country was doing something entirely
different?
Yes, it was as though you were schizophrenic.
Our country had, was two personalities you know.
In one way we may make the wonderful
pronouncements. You know, we, we talk about our
Judeo-Christian ethics and we're going to make
the world a better place for democracy and all
that other jazz.
But then when you get down to the real thing and
you start seeing the way they operate, you
know, things were not, they were not in
consonance. And so I
began to be an angry, frustrated young
Black soldier.
At this time, I wanted to get out of the army.
I'll be very honest with you. After my
experiences, I really did not want to be in
this man's army and.
Especially after having to stand on a
bus when there were no
seats at the back, having to stand up for 100
miles looking at empty seats, yeah,
that didn't endear me to, to my
country.
I couldn't eat in a restaurant.
I had to go around the back and knock on the
door to get food.
And I'm in a uniform.
And I saw PWs, prisoners
of war from Germany being allowed
to go into restaurants and sit down to eat.
And yet I was not entitled to, for that same
opportunity.
Bass shipped out for Europe in October
1944 as part of the 183rd Engineer
Combat Battalion of the US 3rd Army.
Soon they arrived in Belgium, fought in the
Battle of the Bulge, which was the last major
German offensive campaign of the Western Front.
And as laborers, soldiers like Bass
were really first on the front lines and often
last to leave.
They built roads and bridges.
They loaded munitions and supplies.
They disabled landmines.
They transported the wounded and they tended to
the dead.
They crossed into Germany in March of
1945 and by April they had reached
the east central German city of
Weimar.
Just to the north, in the hills above
the city of Weimar sat Buchenwald.
The SS opened the camp
in 1937, primarily for political
prisoners, but they were soon joined by Jews,
Roma, Jehovah's Witnesses, military deserters,
prisoners of war and other groups.
Between July 1937 and April
1945, it is estimated the SS imprisoned
some 250,000 people there.
Buchenwald was one of 44,000 camps,
ghettos, and incarceration sites operated by
Nazi Germany and its allies across
Europe between 1933 and
1945.
And the process of camp liberation itself
was a chaotic affair.
With US forces fast approaching, the Germans
had attempted to evacuate some 30,000 prisoners,
roughly a third of whom they killed or died
in the process.
In the meantime, an underground resistance
network within the camp stormed the watchtowers
and seized control in anticipation of
the approaching Americans who arrived that
afternoon and found 21,000
people there.
In Bass's words:
We went to Weimar, set up our
bivouac area, and then
went immediately with an officer,
about five of us.
We were in the intelligence reconnaissance
section of our unit and we went right
to Buchenwald.
And that was the day that I was to discover
what had really been going on in
Europe under the Nazis, because
I walk through the gates
and I saw Walking
Dead people.
Seriously, walking dead people.
I am not a doctor.
I cannot assess things
that accurately. But in just looking at these
people who were skin and bone
and dressed in
those pajama type uniforms, their heads clean
shaved and
filled with sores due to malnutrition.
And here they were coming towards us,
making all kinds of guttural statements
and using their own language.
And it was very difficult for me to comprehend
what was going on. I just looked at this in
amazement and, and
I said to myself, you know,
my God, you know, who are these people?
What have they done?
What was their crime? You know, it's hard for me
to try to understand why anybody
could have been treated this way, I don't care
what they had done and just didn't
grab me. And I didn't have any
way of thinking, of putting a handle on it.
No frame of reference. I was only 20.
And here you can see the moment that Bass was
just describing, he only spent
one day at Buchenwald, a matter of hours,
really, but the experience fixed
itself permanently in the back of his mind,
although for many years, decades, really,
he never spoke of it.
And he remained stationed in Germany long enough
to watch massive swastikas demolished
off of government buildings in the city of
Nuremberg, before he was shipped to the
Philippines, where he served for another
eight months.
Now, VE day in early May
1945 was jubilant, but
as of May 1945, color lines
snaked across every aspect of American life.
White mobs, vigilante groups and innumerable,
innumerable iterations of local, state and
federal officials police these lines
as they saw fit.
Jim Crow lawmakers vowed to defend the social
and political order at whatever cost.
Even blood banks remained segregated, a
hold out of popular racial science so egregious,
so glaringly parallel to Nazi race law that
it became one of the most heated civil rights
issues of the war years.
Articles and man on the street interviews
published in the Black press in the immediate
wake of VE day indicate that Germany's
total surrender prompted questions about
whether fascism had really been defeated,
whether it could ever be defeated within Western
capitalist societies, and about
whether white Americans were poised to learn
anything from fascism, fascism's reign
and apparent ruin.
As one factory worker told her interviewer,
If the whites haven't learned by now, I guess
they never will.
And here you can see two political cartoons from
the summer of 1945, grappling
with clear,
obvious signs of
anti-Blackness and racism continuing
as the war came to a close.
And as the war came to a close, and really in
the months that followed, racial violence
did surge throughout the United States.
Right. Mobs of white vigilantes were targeting
returning Black veterans.
You saw this deliberate stripping away of
wartime gains through a southern mobilization
in defense of Jim Crow.
In the summer of 1945, in Congress,
lawmakers staged fierce campaigns
on the floor of the Senate, arguing
against fair employment legislation and fought
viciously against widely supported efforts to
eliminate the poll tax and pass federal
anti-lynching legislation.
And there's one really remarkable article from
that summer in which a Black columnist
named Marjorie McKenzie observed that
all of this racist and really explicitly
racist and explicitly antisemitic filibustering
that was happening at the Capitol garnered new
meaning when you
recognize that just a block away,
mere steps away, the Library of Congress, they
had opened an exhibit of mural sized
atrocity photos.
These are scenes from, from concentration camp
liberation.
And thinking about that juxtaposition, McKenzie
wrote, "it has said, it has been
said that is a good thing for Americans to see
the horrors of the German concentration camps
because seeing them will make us resolve never
to allow anything like that to happen here."
But McKenzie doubted such an assertion.
"The military collapse of fascism is going to
leave the world a heritage of fascists without
labels," she wrote.
"To defeat the organized strength of a system of
government without destroying the ideology
upon which it is based is dangerous."
And her argument really
returns to this theme I already mentioned.
Her argument came down to the murkiness,
of the lack of demarcation line,
the instability of the demarcation line
and the vigilance that would be required to
determine where one form of politics
began and, and one,
or one, where one ended and one began, right.
And making that determination before it was too
late.
And for some, claims of American
fascism or a kind of unique form of American
fascism, they were largely rhetorical.
They were a provocative way to tie foreign
affairs to domestic issues and draw attention
to the civil rights cause.
For others, however, the threat of US fascism
was possible and rather urgent.
And for many, I think it was some combination of
those two feelings, some strategy
and some dread.
And either way, they were rooted
in the understanding that white Americans
refused to actually interrogate their history,
their complicity, their insistence on reform
rather than reconstruction.
And early postwar commentary in the Black press
that focused on the afterlife of fascism,
the idea that Hitler had been defeated
but his ideas had not.
The realities and residues of those
ideas, they argued they were still
palpable in American life and
they included racial chauvinism and
nativist sensibility; exclusionary
nationalism defined through legal claims to
whiteness; lost cause nostalgia and
fantasies of white victimhood; a
militant and deputized
citizenry; the mass
caging of internal and external enemies
in reservations, ghettos and detention centers
and prisons.
And after 1945, reckoning with all
of this, African-Americans called for justice.
They called for reflection.
But really, clearly, they called for vigilance.
So they recognized that there was a danger
that fascism was still pending
in a world that had already shown
that they--it wasn't
going to come to terms with, with what it had
just done.
And for Bass, it would take him some time
to, to, to put these connections together.
Upon his return home, he sort of set to make a
life for himself. He started a family.
He got his PhD, he built his career and
he became involved with the civil rights
movement.
The assassination of Martin Luther King in
1968 had a profound impact on him.
And in his testimony, he describes the heartache
and horror that he felt in the wake
of that event.
This was a personal grief and disillusionment
for him personally, but it was something he saw
reflected back tenfold
in the young Black and brown students
at the high school where he served as principal.
So it was around this time to the late 60s,
right around 1970 in particular, that
he started to think about Buchenwald
again.
And one day I came to a classroom,
and in that classroom there was a lady,
and she was trying to talk to the young men who
were not listening to her.
You know, they were doing everything but
listening.
And I stood at the door and I began to realize
that she was a survivor and she
had survived one of the worst camps.
She had survived Auschwitz.
And she was here today on this particular day to
share her experience, her pain, if you will.
And these young men were not listening.
They had their own pain, you know, and I
understood that, you know, the pain of
rejection, the pain of not giving, being
given the kind of recognition you deserve.
I understood all of that. I had been through
there and I knew their
pain, but I also knew her pain.
And so I had to say to them, hold it, fellas,
cool it.
Listen, what she says is
true. I was there.
And so they got quiet for a while.
And once she started telling
her account of what happened at Auschwitz,
they really listened.
And she told them how she lost her grandmother.
Grandfather.
Parents, brothers, sisters, cousins,
all those near and dear who had come into that
camp, all of them had gone to
the gas chambers and had ended up in the ovens.
And of her family, she was the only one
that came out of there.
And they listened.
She shared with them so much
and they asked her questions, which made me know
that she had to reach them.
They came up and looked at the numbers tattooed
on her arm and they
thanked her and they did something
I-- hadn't been done in a long while.
They left that room in silence.
And, of course, she turned to me and of course,
tears were coming down her face and she
thanked me for my intervention.
And wanted
to know more about my experience
at Buchenwald.
And I began to remember.
Bass's own experiences with the exclusionary
racial order of the United
States and in later years, his awareness
of the inequalities that shape the world of his
students coming of age in the late sixties,
all this became the lens through which he came
to process what he saw at Buchenwald.
He realized that the camp was not a singular
place, in his words, but rather evinced
a culmination to white supremacy, the
face of evil, he called it.
Racism, antisemitism, bigotry,
prejudice and all manner of hatred.
Bass concluded that Jim Crow and fascism did
stem from the same roots.
And like many before him, he felt the problem
was that the United States had largely failed in
the necessary project of probing those roots,
those that cut deep across Europe
and its colonies, as well as those that
stretched in hardened networks through its
own rich and bloody soil.
And look what it did to us.
Racism has just about split us so many different
ways 'til we can't live in harmony with one
another, suspicious.
All of this I discovered
as an adult and I didn't get it when I was
young, when I should have had it, because people
didn't want to deal with it. It was an ugly side
of our history and ugly things we want to push
under the rug. We don't want to deal with it.
And I'm saying to people today, you must
face it.
You can't laundry and sanitize our history.
You must take history with its beauty and you
must take it with its degradation.
You've got to deal with it for us to be whole
human beings and and to make a difference.
And this is especially true with young people.
And so I go around telling my story.
And, of course, you know, I get the people
saying, Leon, why do you deal with this?
This is, this is not a Black problem.
I said, hey, it's not a Black problem.
It's not a white problem.
It's a human problem.
And we've got to face it.
And as Dr. King said, injustice
anywhere is the loss of justice
everywhere. You see words to that effect
and it's true. What affects you, affects me.
Your pain has to be my pain and my pain has to
be your pain. And I must somehow convey that to
the young people that I come to.
It's my commitment and somebody says
you, why do you deal with that mess?
You know, I said, I'm sorry.
I know it's been forty something years, but
that doesn't make it go away.
It only makes us become more aware that
we today have to do something that to stop
that which created the Final
Solution and that something
is racism.
Really, racism is that the root of all of
this. Under that umbrella comes bigotry and
prejudice and discrimination, unemployment,
people who are unemployable, large institutions
filled with those who are drug addicts and those
who are criminals, all because somehow we
haven't come to grips with that institution
called racism.
And we have to because we see the ultimate
of racism, which was what I saw in Buchenwald.
And so what do we do?
Do we as educators,
and I use it in the broadest sense because we
all teachers of the young, in our
way of life, do we convey to them
the best that we can be or do
we give them the worst side that we
have?
Do we promote racism through
our apathy?
When we hear and see things, we say nothing,
because we don't want to jeopardize that which
is important to us. Our investment in a job,
our investment among friends.
We don't want to disturb our families.
So no matter what people say or do,
just leave it alone, sweep it under the rug and
somehow it'll go away.
But the skinheads are with us.
The Klan is with us.
It may be dressed in Brooks Brothers suit with
attaché cases.
They may be in, in doctors, they may
be lawyers. They may be the guy who drives a
bus, but they are still with us.
And just to conclude, the steady advance,
a nationwide embrace of the civil rights
movement in the 1950s and '60s
did confirm that the fascistic
filibustering of Mississippi senators had
been their swan song after
all.
These decades saw a substantial decline
in the excessive mob rule and public expressions
of racism, public acts of racism and white
supremacy so pervasive in the age before.
Yet as Bass puts so well, many
of the currents of white supremacy,
but also the vast structures of race and class
inequality in the United States are still with
us. And a significant part of the problem
are Americans to choose every day to buy
into a myth that, a myth of
the United States that for many people does not
exist.
"White people were and are astounded by the
Holocaust in Germany," wrote James Baldwin in
1962. "They did not know that they could act
that way, but I very much doubt whether Black
people were astounded, at least in the same
way." And signaling a heritage
of fascists without labels in the United States,
African-American voices in the 1930s and '40s
laid the groundwork for a longterm challenge to
the patriotic antifascism and narrow myths
of progress, which whitewashed national
memory in the postwar United States.
They helped to forge an antiracist, antifascist
counter heritage and radical organizing
tradition with tremendous coalition building
possibilities, not only across the civil
rights era and the age of Black power, but
also up into our present moment.
Thank you.
Thank you, Anna.
We have a little bit of time for
questions, so if
anyone would like to ask
Anna a question, you can use the Q&A
button or the
chat.
I'll field both of those.
We do have one question already.
And this is a question about the economic
system.
And the question is,
is capitalism to fascism as socialism
is to communism? Is our economic system one
reason it is so difficult for us to recognize
who we are? It's a big question, but to the
heart of it is our economic, is our economic
system or economics somehow tied
up with why we can't
we can't seem to come to terms with
racial inequality.
To a very, to a very big question, I
will offer a brief answer, which is yes,
right. And learning from the
Black radical theorists who were writing
explicitly about this.
Over a hundred years ago, they would say that
the the entire formation of,
of the American economic system was on the basis
of chattel slavery and, and plantation
economics, right? So they would say the two were
entirely caught up together and
anti-Blackness and racial formation was part of
the maintenance of capital and was the sort
of justification for capitalist accumulation
and expansion and extraction
of goods and colonies, right.
So the simple answer is yes.
I think, I think they are entirely tied up
together.
Thanks. All right, Gil has a question
here, fairly long.
I'm going to go ahead and read it because I
think it's worth reading in its entirety.
So Gil found it fascinating that you highlight
how Black American commentators understood
European fascism has centered on racism
rather than about authoritarian forms of
government, as it has been recently discussed
here in the US.
And he thinks that's an extremely important
perspective.
You talk mainly about perceptions of
resemblance between European fascism and the US,
but I wonder if you can talk a bit about the
history of actual legal relationship and
influence.
Just two examples to prompt discussion would be
James Whitman's book, Hitler's American Model
and and the relationship between
Nazi race policy and Jim Crow.
You talk a little bit about that in your talk.
And there's another, I think
Rabinbach, I believe, has an article about
how African-American intellectuals try to draw
on the new postwar concept of genocide coined
by Raphael Lemkin during the Holocaust,
after the Holocaust, to fight lynching in the
South and how it became intertwined with
the with continuing your point, Soviet
depictions of the US as a fascist state.
But those are yeah, those are great questions, I
definitely like the undercurrents of this talk
and things that I sort of had to cut in order to
make this fit the time.
So first of all, right, that's a little bit what
I was trying to get at, right.
That as early as like, literally before
the march on Rome in 1922,
the Black press is sort of having
debates like are the fascists like Klansmen?
And oftentimes they would say no, because the
Klans-- the fascists are a little more
dignified. Right.
Sort of. But, but
there was this feeling early on that was about
this compare and contrast that was pretty
abstract, that was about,
you know, parallels, similarities, echoes.
But also from the beginning, they were looking
at moments of direct exchange and
alliances. Right. So it's, it was something like
just a few months after the fascists in Italy
came to power,
a leader in the Ku Klux Klan announced that he
wanted to forge an alliance with them in order
to bring the Klan struggle for white supremacy
to Europe. Right.
So you, so you do have direct
admiration, borrowing and exchange.
You also, of course, have massive routes of, of,
of interaction in the field of eugenics.
And I think there is a very famous comment where
some American eugenicist said the Nazis are
beating us at our own game.
And, of course, you have the research that, that
James Whitman's book
puts so well. Right. That, that, the, the,
the Nazi government did study
the kind of elaborate systems of American
race law to try to figure out what did and did
not work. And were actually quite perturbed.
I mean, recognize that
many things wouldn't work in the context of Nazi
Germany, but learned a lot specifically about,
um anti, anti--
sort of racial terms of citizenship, so,
so the Nazis also learned a lot from the Johnson
Reed Act, the very restrictive immigration law
passed in the United States in 1924,
and also miscegenation laws.
Right.
So, so you do have these moments of direct
exchange, which I think are also fascinating
because the archive is just full of
people tracking the parallels on both levels,
right, on the kind of more abstract level
of parallel agendas, and on actual
routes of exchange.
And really quickly to your second question, I
mean, that's, that to me is, is such
a key component in the wave of
sort of in the immediate postwar moment, there
actually three different petitions submitted by
African-Americans to the UN.
On behalf of-- so the first one by
a group called the National Negro Congress in
1946, that was calling for an end to
discrimination. The second one by the NAACP
in 1947 to another kind of coming together
a human rights convention.
And then the last one was in
1951 by the Civil Rights Congress, specifically
demanding the United States be charged with
genocide. And I think everyone should read that
petition, We Charge Genocide.
It's extensive. It's two hundred and forty
pages.
But, but it shows a very keen,
really brilliant, really sharp, but
no less provocative interpretation
of the actual legal crime
of genocide. Actually, Raphael Lemkin
disapproved of the petition.
But I think that story, really you have to
understand it in the context the Cold War.
And even to see how much the American public
widely praised the 40--
the '46 and '47 petitions, but by
1951, condemned it across
the board, right. And it's significant that that
the National Negro Congress in 1946 and
the Civil Rights Congress in 1951 were both
directly affiliated with the Communist Party.
Right. And that is the kind of other
undercurrent of this whole talk
that the, we're talking about the heyday
of radical interracial trade
unionism and communist organizing in the United
States. But again, what I think is so
fascinating about this archive is just explodes
past that pretty quickly.
And I think what's really significant is after
the Hitler-Stalin pact, which was such a huge
blow to the left, the language of antifascism
lived on, right. It really continued to be a
popular vernacular related
to but also unmoored from the
kind of political and ideological commitments
of, of the Communist International.
Great question.
And great, great answer.
So we just have a couple more questions
and then I think we'll, we'll
start to wrap things up.
This is also another big question,
but I think the talk, it's
clear that the talk would bring a question like
this up.
It seems as if there should be great empathy and
understanding between the American Jewish
community and the African-American community.
How would you explain, though, then, that there
is such times of moments of such animosity
and conflict between these two groups
in the past and the present?
Yeah, no, that's that's a great question.
And I think...we,
can we go over, can we go I don't want can we go
past--?
Sure.
OK, I don't we, I don't, I don't want to have to
rush these things because it seems very serious.
So, I mean, I think that's actually reason
enough to just go and sit and watch Leon
Bass's full testimony
because what exists underneath the surface of
his whole,
his whole oral history is that the interview
was conducted in 1988, which
I think was this particularly heated moment
of tension and,
eventually, with the Crown Heights riots, sort
of outright violent clashing
between Black Americans and Jewish Americans.
Right. And.
I mean, I think my interest in this
archive and all of these calls for
solidarity, and all these calls for sort of
building a movement, an alliance of the interwar
period was in-- was
sort of in pursuit of a larger
story than what I had heard for many years of my
education, right, of these tensions, of the
pervasiveness of
anti-Black racism amongst Jews and antisemitism
amongst African-Americans.
Sometimes in the archive you do find
people writing editorials in the Black press
saying, like, we have to stop this, right.
Sort of condemning the explicit antisemitism
of groups, right. And a lot of that was sort of
rooted in local, I think, either
sort of, in the case of, of, of
particular cities, like New York,
local issues, local tensions.
But I think an example I really like, so that,
the book I mentioned, this is someone else asked
about book recommendations and one of the ones I
mention, which I think has such a beautiful
example to think about this,
Michael Rothberg, who wrote
this great called Multidirectional Memory, it's
his attempt to try to understand how it's sort
of less...looking
at Holocaust memory, decolonization
and civil rights movements and events that
happened at the same time, what are the moments
of collaboration and cross referencing rather
than competition and his explanation for
least in the United States, why the competition
happens. As he uses the example, he was writing
a book when they were getting ready to open the
National Museum of African-American History on
the National Mall.
A lot of people were struck by the sort of
symbol that
that museum was taking up, the literal
last plot
of the National Mall.
And he said for, for racialized groups in the
United States, for minorities in the United
States, for groups who are subject to racial
persecution and prejudice in the United States,
there's often a feeling that there is a limit
to the amount of tension and the amount of
recognition that they can get, right, so there's
like a competition, competition a la real estate
for who can be represented, who can be
protected, who can receive dignity.
And his argument is essentially, right,
that, that justice and solidarity
and the pursuit of human dignity should not be
like real estate, right.
That it should be rooted in
collaboration. So I think, my research,
I've just been over the years has been so struck
by how many other
conversations were happening.
But I think it is significant and it's important
to recognize the violence
and contention as well.
And I think someone else had a book, I think
another, if you want to like, what was, do you
want to get the specific book recommendations
stuff? And I'm surrounded by the books I used to
write this talk. I mean, I think to me like an
amazing classic place to start, truly,
the book that got me into all of this is
Glenda Gilmore, Yale Professor Glenda
Gilmore's Defying Dixie.
Not only is it just
an incredible, extensive history, she's also
just such a beautiful writer and a brilliant
scholar.
So I really strongly recommend this and then
two more, that I just have all around me.
One is Susan Pennybacker's
From Scottsboro to Munich,
which looks more at the Black diaspora and
concentrates in Great Britain.
And then finally, this just came out and this
was the book I quoted from,
the US Antifascism Reader.
It's really amazing,
these very recent collection of all sorts
of different political perspectives, all sorts
of different arguments, all sorts of different
assessments from the 1920s
up through the present.
I dropped a couple of links to, to
those titles
as well in the chat, but
you're welcome to get in touch with
me, my email's on the website.
And I can, I can provide you with
more information about those readings, if you
like.
If there aren't any other questions,
then I'd like to extend
my thanks again to Anna for some
really enlightening presentation.
And thank you to everyone who came today.
And we'll see you next time.
I thank you all so much and you're welcome to
send me an email if you want to, if you have
questions or want to chat.